olivia rodrigo celebrated her big night
at the grammys by singing and sliving
with paris hilton
this is living
and now we really just want a paris
olivia duet i was so excited on sunday
olivia took home not one not two but
three grammys
best pop vocal album best pop solo
performance and best new artist
i can't even process it how do you
celebrate tonight
i'm going with my friends which will be
fun they all came to vegas to support so
i'm gonna go hang out with them and
after the big show the 19 year old
songbird celebrated in style throwing an
after party with a little help from the
heiress
[Music]
the 41 year old dj the bash standing in
a booth in front of a giant screen
reading baby's first grammys
they also hit the dance floor together
as paris serenaded olivia with her 2006
hit stars are blind
legendary
don't tell my parents
and if liv's plunging baby blue dress by
blue marine looks familiar it's because
it is the custom creation was made as a
tribute to the dress paris wore on her
21st birthday back in 2002
later paris commented on this snap of
olivia cradling her grammy gold writing
quote so proud of you beautiful best
time celebrating with you last night
she's 19 and she's doing all this i feel
very lucky to be able to do this yes
yeah safe to say this 19 year old is
crushing it e.t caught up with the
driver's license singer on the red
carpet before the big show i've just
watched the grammys religiously since i
was so young and just to be here and
perform up on that stage is just
such an honor and she opened up about
her upcoming sour tour and her disney
plus documentary driving home to you
i've always been so attracted to really
emotional songs there's been such a
great reception for driving home to you
how's that and how good does that be
yeah it feels amazing we worked really
hard on the film and
i said it before but i'm going on tour
actually like literally the second we
finished the grammys i'm going on tour
and so i wanted to give my fans who
maybe um wouldn't be able to make it to
a concert uh something that they could
watch for a you know a little bit of new
content so i'm happy that we did that
[Music]